If I look at my Twitterizer Tester, I now have a test for reversing, how did I
ever program without loops? Inside the twitterizer class, I have to implement
the reverse method. I want to look at every letter in the string post, but I
want to start from the end, and work my way backwards. As I did last time, I'll
start with an empty string backwards, that I'm going to add letters to, as I
see new letters. But this time I'll start I at the last letter in post. And go
as long as i is not less than 0. I mean, as long as i, is not less than 0.
Decrimenting i by 1 each time. Inside the loop, I want to record every single
letter I see into backwards, and then I want to return backwards. When I run
the program, it didn't break the first one, and now reverse works, as well.